alright thanks my name is Peter
Baumgartner i'm here today with a plea
to you to please build dumb things i do
not mean dumb in any derogatory sense a
dumb thing to me is just something that
you build for entertainment value or to
learn something or for a creative outlet
when you're trying to learn something
and it's really simple the epitome of a
dumb thing to me is when I'm talking to
my mom on the phone and she asked me
what I did last weekend and I explained
to her like the Twitter bot that i built
and her responses oh that's nice that's
the epitome of a dumb thing so I'm going
to share some dumb things that I've
built hopefully to inspire you to just
build dumb things and put them out in
the world it's a great way to learn
about new tools and just kind of explore
the world of Python so the first dumb
thing that I'm going to talk about is
this Twitter bot that I built that
basically generates random accolades for
the City of Raleigh there was there was
a time when this whole thing was coming
about Raleigh was getting a bunch of
accolades for a bunch of different
magazines i thought well can i randomly
generate them and have them make sense
so like a lot of generative art and
creative things a lot of it is total
nonsense but there are some pretty
comical ones if you if you pick and
choose so some recent good ones these
are all at least from the last week
we've got Raleigh's in the top five for
vetoing bandsaws so get those bandsaws
out of here best cities for
ill-conceived unbelting shower rooms I
know almost all unbelting shower rooms
are probably ill-conceived so I think
that's a bad idea faking sadism I'll let
you interpret that one and of course
number two in humping soaps I don't know
whether that's you know whether you want
to hump soaps or it's soaps that are
humping each other I'll leave that up to
you but I learned a lot of things just
doing this about the Twitter API I used
NLT k and wordnet to basically try and
figure out what forms of the words would
fit into these these mad libs here and
also this is just a Heroku a script
uploaded to Heroku and then just use
Heroku scheduler to have it run every
hour so that's my first dumb thing my
second dump thing is Santana bot Santana
bot is really great so I got this
raspberry pi for Christmas I was like
what am I going to do with it I was
starting to go through this some of the
tutorials and the first thing you learn
is how to connect a button and then like
print out that you press the button so I
was like okay well i'm just going to
substitute printing out that i press the
button with playing santana's 1981 hit
winning so this dumb thing all you do is
you press the button and all it does is
plays the chorus from Santana's hit song
winning that's all it does it's like the
worst jukebox ever but it's great I
learned a lot about electronics learn
how to program with a raspberry pi and
use a GPIO shell scripting and again the
Twitter API this tweets whenever you
press the button so i can share in the
love of santana the pup potty tracker so
my wife and I have two dogs and we have
this problem where we forget the last
time that we let out the dogs and they
will remember for us by going to the
bathroom in the apartment so I bought
these amazon dash buttons on an amazon
prime day they were only a dollar and
you can hack those so that basically
they still connect to your wireless but
don't actually buy anything from amazon
which is awesome so you basically say i
push this button and i have a raspberry
pi running that detects oh you push this
button add this item to the database and
that item is when the dog did that
certain biological function this is a
great motivator actually to get people
to dog-sit I don't know what it is but
people really like pushing the buttons
it's fantastic and then I've got this
web app you can go there and also keep
us accountable for letting our dogs
outside I learned a lot here to the
Raspberry Pi as a server just have
something continually running sniffing
whether these buttons are trying to
connect to the internet just use MongoDB
to store all that there's a free mongodb
host called M lab they got a free tier
and then this is just a flask app with
some basic bootstrap to get it all
mobile friendly and whatnot and my final
dumb thing is it's working this is great
when you previously had something that
wasn't working and it now works all it
does is it plays this stupid 3 second
video of Anakin Skywalker from Star Wars
Episode one the Phantom Menace when he
screams
it's working when he makes his pod racer
work so it's a nice thing when I'm
feeling good that I finally like
debugged something and I just go to this
and I'm like all right Anakin thank you
those are all my dumb things thanks for
listening to me and please build your
own dumb things and put them out in the
world thank you so much no joke required
um all right Julie is up now and then
following her Peter parente up perfect
great more technical difficulties I can
see what's going on yeah you just all
have to come over here stand behind them
monitor yeah you could do in the laptop
ram
try unplugging it
yeah I know there may be this uh system
just doesn't like max what keep them
entertained you want to tell some jokes
James yeah you'll have to keep them PG
ok g y'all have to give them G yeah ken
are you up for it have you all heard the
one about the broken pencil ok don't
worry it's pointless ok cool so my name
is Julie and I'm a PhD student in
chemical engineering and since I have a
captive audience I thought I'd tell you
about my research so today I'd like to
introduce you to how our academic lab is
using basic data science skills in
Python to improve bio processing so on
screen is an antibody in our bodies
produce antibodies in response to germs
and a new type of therapy called
immunotherapy is using antibodies to
mimic how our body naturally fights
disease and antibodies are really
powerful because they specifically
target diseased cells so you can you you
can attach drugs to antibodies to
deliver the drugs directly to the site
of infection so this method is used to
treat a lot of diseases like Alzheimer's
arthritis and even cancer and we produce
these synthetic antibodies in lab by
reprogramming cells to make them
unfortunately though we can't just
program the cells to make antibodies
they also make impurities and these
impurities cause undesirable side
effects and patients and they must be
removed from our medicines and so that's
where my research comes in so antibodies
are large molecules now they're actually
really small you can't see them with the
naked eye but in the world of biology
they're really big molecules and they're
made up of tiny amino acid subunits in
some of these impurities defer from the
target antibody drug product wise little
as one amino acid
out of hundreds so removing these
impurities is necessary and important
but it's also a significant challenge so
companies currently spend many months
and many millions testing hundreds of
filters and conditions to purify these
new antibody drugs and they even use
robots to all of these experiments and
all these experiments have to be
repeated for each new antibody drug
because each antibody has unique
properties in each production mixture
has unique set of impurities so our labs
goal is to harness all this data to help
companies develop better faster and more
economical purification processes for
antibody drugs so my research will help
guide filter selection I'm really
interested in connecting the protein
surface properties with how they perform
in the filters and so I'm doing this
using machine learning and other basic
data science tools in Python and
scikit-learn so as a model system our
lab made a library of different antibody
fragments that deferred by one or two
amino acids so first we collected data
on all of these variants by doing a lot
of experiments like years worth of
experiments and now we're using all of
this data to develop kuser models or
quantitative structure-activity
relationship models and so we're
connecting um we're using these models
to uh to connect the protein surface
properties to how they interact in the
filters and okay I had some more about
how like the specifics but apparently
setup took longer than I didn't account
for a setup time in uh in my speech but
yeah so if you want to know more I guess
come find me later to hear the second
half thank you very much Julie it's very
informative um alright so next up is
Peter um and after that Eric you I know
you're around yeah okay doc in my blind
spot so okay
yeah by design right obviously okay uh
and yet another mac failure there goes
my time it's ticking come on yeah time
for another joke so why ask you got like
jokes okay you'll see that almost all
right so lightning talk five cool cool
Jupiter things I think they're cool
we'll see what you think in five minutes
here we go ready okay number one how
many people use docker like docker cool
fudendo there is a set of Jupiter
pre-configured Jupiter docker containers
you download them you type docker run
and you're up and running with Jupiter
and you can get things with spark pre
built in that's what this little
animation showing the Allspark notebook
has Scala our Python pre-configured and
you got a Jupiter notebook server as
soon as I go to the right URL in the
video there's one thank you check it out
it's on github too we did a tutorial
talk on this the other day but if you
have a nerd of it there is the dashboard
extensions for Jupiter they let you
arrange parts here notebook into like a
little web application this video is
just showing it happening right inside
the Jupiter no Pope you can actually
deploy these as a little web apps so you
can see a little Scotch dashboard here
for selecting a scotch that you might
like give it another statute you've
tried before so dragon moving around you
could share these things pretty cool
check it out next one you can actually
with another extension out in Jupiter
this is the Jupiter Colonel gateway you
could actually annotate cells in your
notebook with little restful verbs and
endpoints and you can turn your notebook
into a web server web api REST API this
is handy if you don't want to build a UI
like a dashboard you could actually have
another person come along who's good to
JavaScript and things and build your UI
for you you just work on the the back
end so Jupiter Colonel gateways the name
of the project for that one how many
people have tons and tons of notebooks
and they're trying to find something to
in the past and they can't because they
got to click through all the untitled
one through 1000
you know so there's another extension
called the Jupiter content management
extension you can actually search your
own notebooks those full-text search
over the inputs and mark down and things
like that you can see it happening here
it's a tiny video it looks better on a
full screen obviously and you just click
them and it opens and it's better than
clicking through them all number five
kind of combines again the content
manager extensions once you search and
find these notebooks min Reagan Kelly
actually worked on this originally you
can import them as Python module so you
actually make note books that are
reusable libraries of functions and you
can search firm you can click insert
into notebook see it injects is giant
name which is a really long name of a
notebook and I can start calling
functions on it I think this video is a
little long i donno if it's gonna get to
the point but you could see it
autocompletes and there we go and i got
one bonus in case you didn't know i hope
people realize this presentation is
actually a notebook being hosted mb
viewer and viewed on and be viewer
Shinsei hosts hosts and github viewed on
mb viewer as a slideshow so built into
the notebook you don't have to install
anything today you just go to view and
you turn on the slide toolbar and you
can actually turn yourselves into slides
and another mins awesome extensions you
can upload as a gist and then you go to
mb viewer and we got this really cool
inception thing going on we're watching
a video of the slideshow that i was
making before I don't even know how to
explain it but there it is right so and
that's it there's the links i can post
it later i'll tweet it out thank you
thank you Peter Jupiter looks better on
a full screen um alright so up next is
Eric and after Eric will have Christine
you're right oh she and my blind spot
still too she around oh there you are
sorry oh okay you're behind me the whole
time alright so I've got another bad
joke
to frustrate Eric with and I got this
really excited you off the stage for i'm
gonna forgot oh there there it is it
works okay that's on your back just give
me a terminal there you go go yeah oh
well down saving me oh my god it's I've
been mirrored I don't know how to do
this now okay i'm gonna try and all
right so uh download all right what is
this terminal yeah it's super easy look
at this all right ah ok bash all right
so bash where where am I all right uh
let's see if he has mini condo which I
hope he does know it like it like
seriously was here is not gonna go uh
downloads mini Conda wasn't in downloads
it's on downloads oh my god here we go
alright so mini Conda I'm going to
install this in in batch mode into temp
mini Conda oh my god thank you guys I
try to do this on a monitor that is
literally 40 feet away because my screen
if you can't tell is completely blank
so okay so we are now installing and
installing and more installing okay so
export path equals temp mini Conda bin
colon path so I don't nuke everything
which Conda ok we are know that conduct
great so Conda update dash dash all oh
wait I actually want to you can
regenerate this later move the condo RC
so we know that is completely all right
Conda info dash a just just to show you
that i have no Conda RC yep no con Darcy
ok so Conda update all dash see Conda
for so we're going to overwrite the
entire install of mini Conda from condo
forge not have to probably shrink this
down oh my god yeah it's so easy to read
look at that why well no I buzz I'm not
going to download it over conference
Wi-Fi because it'll be the rest of this
talk but basically you can see that
everything is going to be upload
everything is going to be overwritten by
Conda Forge which is awesome so what
else can we install from Conda forage
tensorflow if I can smell it also not
going to download it because it's very
big but you can install tensorflow ah
anything else that you guys care about
that's it sits off the bottom of the
screen oh my god Conda install Jesus all
right no what is not okay so enough of
that um I literally can't even get all
right okay how active is this let's now
okay let's see there it is crafts
alright let's see if the spool up how
much time do I have left like four
seconds sweet alright so that is the
commit graph for Conda forge you can see
that this line is 200 and it's mostly
due to this guy John Kirk I'm who's
amazing yeah so super active it really
took off around March of this year now
how many packages are there again let me
move this over so you can see the URL
anaconda that org slash Conda forge
there are a lot of packages 1159
packages which is actually more than
anaconda then continuum will give you on
their official channel by about a factor
of two super family group of people you
can install all kinds of great stuff
from them and here we go Conda info
Conda forge / Python no [ __ ] shoot shoot
need the Anaconda client so that I can
access that please go quickly yes that's
shocking Conda Ford Python if you really
want weird versions of Python you can
get them on Conda for it including one
point oh three point six alpha and to
point out so with that I will leave you
thank you thank you Eric you've never
coded in Python one it is a trip okay
Christine you're up next and after
Christine bill you're after her so okay
perfect
I'm not going to use any slide sir they
won't be technical problems I must
statistics PhD student but I did my
undergrad and masters in electrical
engineering and to be honest I think it
is sarcastic that I currently work in
the statistics field for research and I
hope to become a statistician after I
graduate because when i was in middle
school and high school I hated
statistics so much starting in middle
school I wanted to challenge myself to
try to finish one year earlier and at
grade eight the teachers told me that
the test that I have to pass what to
take the same midterms as the great
night do and then if I score above their
mean by more than one and a half
standard deviations then it is
considered a passing score and this is
required for each subject and then on
first try the exam was very easy and
then I scored 95 over a hundred points
but I didn't pass because the standard
deviation was very high because like
many students score high but some people
didn't study at all and then the minimum
required passing was 98 points
fortunately the teachers gave me a
second try and then I finally realized
that they were helping me by making the
questions very rare difficult so I
thought I thought that difficult
questions were very difficult and felt
frustrated and then I scored only 19 but
it was a passing score and the teachers
even told me that you only need a 70
something to pass so I went off and
finished one year earlier in middle
school but the problem was I started to
hate statistics because it was I have
the same level of same level of ability
but it could be changed so so much
and then in high school I continue to
hate statistics because we weren't
allowed a calculator in math and then
the teachers tried to challenge us by
giving very difficult numbers and I
thought that was very complicated and I
thought and then I didn't like it so I
thought statistics was used to torture
people and make people feel bad then I
went to college and I majored in
electrical engineering I left I like
applied math but I decided not to do the
math major because I knew if I work if I
do a math major I'll have to take more
statistics than I was interested in but
in the electrical engineering I missed
one point what was that I mean miss one
thing is that in the sophomore year we
had to take a required course
probability of status and statistics
Hivers things started to change because
I realized that the standard deviation
is just one line of code no more cargo
no more complicated calculated
calculations we can use a calculator and
we're also I don't also learned to solve
real-life problems such as signal
processing okay it is transmitted during
a noisy channel and then we can see like
it 0 but when we observe that as one we
can calculate the false positive rate
and the false negative rate so things
became more and more interesting then I
went on to take more statistics and
applied math courses and in my Master's
I even worked on thus how to compare
distributions on Facebook beta and by
the time I was applying for PhD programs
I had a big mental debate on whether i
should do a statistics or a applied math
or a scientific computation PhD and then
i finally decided on statistics because
of two reasons the first reason is that
it doesn't require GRE subject tests
and the second one is that if i choose
statistics there are a lot of options
that i can work on for interdisciplinary
projects and four years later I'm glad
that I made the right choice because it
opens up for a lot of new process
possibilities and applications the
lesson that I learned is that be open to
new fields and don't be don't own don't
be limited to the past bad experiences
because you never know what the new
field can bring you opportunities thank
you thank you christine all right bill I
think you're up and then that's I I
think we're out of time though right
isn't it keep going all right if you
guys are okay we have more time in for
that so then the next person ah is
Charlotte so cool all right go ahead
take it away awesome good afternoon i'm
bill newman and i'm very new to the data
science space but I'm not new to IT I've
been in the IT space professionally for
just shy of 30 years and in that time
almost almost 20 of those years as some
flavor of database administrator or data
database developer so I'm speaking
historically but it may not necessarily
apply because I'm new to the Python
Python world but history doesn't repeat
but it rhymes historically developers
have used the database or data storage
as just a place to persist their data
and they have historically done it very
sloppily and it's always been a
hard-fought battle sometimes almost to
blows but but we've won out and
developers have a sense of data
discipline data management but now with
the data science moving away from the IT
space and being more closely
married to business managers they are
falling away from the IT oversight and I
think it's a whole new a whole new genre
of developers and it concerns me that
I'm starting to see some of those same
problems with big data because you can
put your data and brute brute force it
back you really don't have to worry too
much about how it is or where it is
because the hardware will see you
through you'll get it back so I it could
don't lose out don't forget your data
discipline and data management skills
keep them always in mind additionally I
come from a military background and
let's speak as far as information and
the tools that you build it's true in
intelligence work that the data you grab
is unclassified until you develop an
interest in it and compile it and now
it's classified let's go with the the
predictive models that you build you
spend all your time tuning them getting
them just right it's good and now in the
enterprise you have built a decision
maker which is very valuable but
historically developers don't come from
a security mindset they're less
concerned about securing those items
securing the tools they've built and
it's always been again a hard fought
battle to take the to teach them to
secure their products to keep them
contained in a secure environment and to
worry about security access rights but
again the to the environments that you
have are now your own not so much in
many places with IT oversight
so you build a decision maker that's
very good that your organizations rely
upon but now put some mind to securing
those things and protecting them because
if you lose them if somebody grabs it
now they know how your organization is
going to make its decisions because you
handed it to them so again i may not i'm
a i'm new to the space so this may not
be as much a concern because i haven't
had a chance to see how things are
developing but i charge all of us to be
mindful stewards of the things we build
and the things we have thank you thank
you so much all right so next up is
Charlotte uh also slide lists oh thank
you so much now is worth uh yeah great
lady talk oh thanks come back next year
all right so I just wanted to get up and
talk for a little bit about pie ladies
and community involvement so it was at
first I want to make a correction from
the closing slide I did not actually get
a job at the conference it is true that
I am starting on Monday at cactus and
I'm very excited about that but that did
not get the job here per se anyway um so
that being said another life changing
event has happened for me in the past
couple of weeks is that I was asked to
become the primary organizer of Pi
ladies anybody who is a local pilot ease
anybody who's familiar with the local
pilot ease may be aware that it's been a
very quiet group lately and that is
largely due to I had two primary
organizers one of whom just had a baby
and the other one has just been over
committed and so it was decided that it
was appropriate to pass the torch and so
I am going to take the lead and we are
working on revitalizing the group so if
you've been aware of Pi ladies and kind
of dismissed it because there wasn't
much going on that is about to change so
anyone who is interested in being a part
of pi ladies I encourage you to go to
the meetup group and there's going to be
a lot more happening I'm really excited
about the directions we can take it that
being said I also wanted to mention the
tri Python group and it's been mentioned
a couple times already during the
conference pi ladies in this area works
closely with try Python and we hope for
that to continue and I also wanted to
mention it for those of you who are not
local or even those of you who are local
look in your communities and see what
groups are out there because it makes a
huge difference in the strength of the
community as just having a conversation
with somebody earlier today about how
one of the things that strikes me about
the Python community it is very much a
community you have been to different
kinds of user groups and all this sort
of thing and I'm always struck by how
much the Python communities are that
community it's not just a place to go
and share knowledge that certainly
happens but there is that camaraderie
and people working together and
supporting each other and that is so
important to nurture that so I very much
encourage everybody to go out and find
whatever your local community groups are
get involved show up even if you don't
have much time you can still show up for
a meeting now and then and you never
know who you might make a difference in
the life of you know to throw back to
Carol's keynote speech speech you never
know who you are going to affect with
even just a short conversation so I
encourage everybody to get involved in
your local community even if you think
you've got nothing to contribute I would
tell you if you'd asked me a month ago I
would have said I don't know i could
probably contribute something but yeah I
don't have that much I don't have too
much background you know what here I'm
standing here becoming the primary
organizer of pi ladies because people
liked my ideas and wanted to see my
enthusiasm go into that endeavor you
never know what you're going to effect
thank you so much Charlotte all right
now we have a JC and there there may be
magic apparent yeah where there is magic
okay um and then following JC we have
Jason so Jason okay yes around James J
no we're skipping James as Jason ok
Jason's on around so let's give him it
don't the kids are gone to so uh uh uh
and then humans at PI data I think yep
which is Lucia so hi everyone just to
start I have like no now a free personal
battery great but I'm gonna clean
everything just to make sure it's tough
on a clean plate and what I'm gonna do I
going to deal the wheel and just show
you how you build a wheel I'm gonna do a
I'm going to time it we're going to take
a minute and 30 second a wheel and I
can't just going to a parallel below
that with a 42 42 why not okay because
you need to go in the virtual
environment site done on C Python on
wheel yes and ok and here we are
building a C Python on wheel it's
downloading Python it's configuring
doing the introspection and and then
you're going to build the thing and and
yeah and then and then they're going to
show you in the meantime today I i put
my bug socks and i'm pretty happy about
it
and yeah yeah and like what oh it's
going very fast yeah I don't have 42
cold butter but it's pretty good like
set up a nice um and it's going I've 64
gig of memory on that mansion by the way
and oh yeah yeah it too much but I
should have taken off cough to be able
to use all the memory and the drive is
pretty cool too envian me and I've like
nan Jie Jie Liang gigabytes in reading
and yes it's cool i mean you can do is
done things like Peter was talking about
doing dumb stuff great i'm getting the
wheel now you see C Python will awesome
let's check if I got the wheel if I got
the wheel yeah and and I of the let's
clear everything to make sure you sit
and I got the wheel like here but now
let's install the wheel and I'm gonna go
in test and I'm gonna clear everything
and I'm going to make sure that I don't
have anything installed yet northern OC
Python will are going to install it pip
install and I just give the path to the
wheel gonna make things a bit bigger
make sure you see things ok installing
oh it's installed great I'm gonna go go
back to something bit smaller because it
is more things can happen on the screen
and then I start Python ok its version 2
7 10 no big deal oh I mean you can see
it 27 10 like here and now I go back
small it's fine out your back because I
have time you know and then I do import
see Titan as a SJC why not and then and
then I gonna do JC dot take over and
then I wanna happen well I mean we build
that like just before the talked and
then it's like that's an ascii art i'm
not sure it is but i'm adam it's cool
you need to add do I think before I look
you look
something it's like cool things to do
but but now what do we have what is that
thing yeah it's pretty useless but now
let's just do import sis and let's do
sis that version and what do we have
here we have Python I'll you come let's
go let's go let's go big now yeah and we
have its Python a 3.5 phone too and it's
very real 3.5 photo is not just a string
and printing on the screen too yeah and
it means yeah you can build a we love of
C Python cipa there's no we love C
Python we could put it on pip could
build it with with many linux and I've
will for any version of a fight on
that's it and yeah and now to show you
that it's it's oh yeah i just did
control the exited the first one and now
i can take over again and i can leave
again you know that's not it and okay
now let me show you how does that things
work clear and i have a set up that py
pretty standard stuff as can you see
things the red now you can see it can
you yeah no yeah no okay let's change
hey let's i liked it look at that it's
better no hahaha no anyway I gonna talk
and you're gonna just trust me and
that's gonna be alright yep you have the
version 3.5 point too we just specify
few option the package description
metadata like a regular wheel and that's
pretty much and in the folder what do we
have oh if I can type I guess I and in
the folder I just have a the source and
my set of the py and and that's it voila
thank you so much JC hello everybody if
you still do not know me that means I've
done a great job at letting all the
speakers and presenters do what they
were supposed to do which is give you
lots of information
inspire you continue to help you pursue
your career and your dreams but I also
wanted to give you a little background
off what was actually going on behind
everything here I'm starting off with a
few pictures and I'm ending with my most
favorite part the numbers the heart
numbers first of all it all began with
two people at a bar it was actually not
a joke it was two people at a bar after
Evita and Chris came to me it was like
you know what I think we should get the
Python conference here and I was like I
was naive enough to say sure count me in
after that we had our very first board
meeting with a very big board we wrote
on itself ideas on and you can already
see a few of the face as you've seen
across the last three days guiding you
along the way helping with the setup
making sure everything runs smoothly
afterwards we kept the momentum going we
had more and more meetings and then what
happened that one of our report meetings
the man bailed out you know what there
was not a problem for us we kept going I
guess what the men joined us again and
we needed a bigger table then one day we
got very excited because we had our
webpage life so we were like stuff is
getting real right now we need to hold
it now because we promised the world
because we announced it on the internet
and when you have something in the
internet it must be true this is how by
date I Carolina started last but not
least we did a ton of setup work and I'm
so grateful for everybody having join us
and the days before to make sure
everything is set up and we finished two
hours earlier than planned on Tuesday
evening that means we got to eat and
actually go home and sleep before the
conference starts this is why you saw so
many friendly faces starting Wednesday
morning because everybody did have a
good night of sleep which is apparently
unusual for a conference organised
here are some tips and here are some
statistics on making sure this
conference is reproducible first of all
send emails early have conversations
early it turns out the the very first
email in my inbox with the word PI data
was from march to was from april 2015
apparently were quite low in organizing
a conference between just me and chris
we had about two hundred forty three
different email threads going back and
forth over the last year or year and a
half longest email chain was about 57
emails going back and forth the toughest
subject we did have to address that
nearly made us cancel PI data Carolinas
to be honest or chp to and I'm glad we
did not and I'm very excited that we
were able to focus on diversity making
sure we have a safe environment for
everybody who joined us we also have an
interesting statistics I was doing a
little bit of sentiment analysis on the
emails received that it turns out we do
have a PO lightest email sender which is
very Cleary a wonderful and amazing AV
support the latest email send was around
three a.m. at night now my colleagues
please cover your ears my work
colleagues should not hear that but the
earliest email was 523 am so someone is
zoomed it was actually the latest email
upset in addition to all those stats we
had so many volunteers and we could not
have done it without the countless
volunteer hours that everybody has put
in so to all the volunteers here I give
you tons and tons of gratitude and
please come to me afterwards for a token
of appreciation and some nerdy things to
feed your Python knowledge
also that one's for you Chris here is
one thing you can definitely expect from
us tonight which is taking a good
night's rest so we will not send any
emails until like three days from now
because we're sleeping thank you all for
coming and I hope to see you North
Carolina again next year